what are some moonshot ideas you think
might make significant progress towards
AGI maybe in other ways what are big
blockers that we're missing now so
basically I am fairly bullish on our
ability to build agis uh basically
automated systems that we can interact
with and are very human-like and we can
interact with them in a digital realm or
Physical Realm currently it seems most
of the models that sort of do these sort
of magical tasks are in a text drone
um I think uh as I mentioned I'm
suspicious that the text realm is not
enough to actually build full
understanding of the world I do actually
think you need to go into pixels and
understand the physical world and how it
works so I do think that we need to
extend these models to consume images
and videos and train on a lot more data
that is multimodal in that way
if you think you need to touch the world
to understand it also well that's the
big open question I would say in my mind
is if you also require the embodiment
and the ability to uh sort of interact
with the world run experiments and have
a data of that form then you need to go
to Optimus or something like that and so
I would say Optimus in some way is like
a hedge
in AGI because it seems to me that it's
possible that just having data from the
internet is not enough
if that is the case then Optimus may
lead to AGI because Optimus would I to
me there's nothing Beyond optimism you
have like this humanoid form factor that
can actually like do stuff in the world
you can have millions of them
interacting with humans and so on and uh
if that doesn't give a rise to AGI at
some point like not I'm not sure what
will
um so from a completeness perspective I
think that's the uh that's a really good
platform but it's a much harder platform
because uh you are dealing with atoms
and you need to actually like build
these things and integrate them into
society so I think that path takes
longer but it's much more certain and
then there's a path of the internet and
just like training these compression
models effectively uh on uh trying to
compress all the internet
and that might also give these agents as
well compress the internet but also
interact with the internet yeah so it's
not obvious to me
in fact I suspect you can reach AGI
without ever entering the physical world
and which is a little bit more
uh concerning because
it might that results in it happening
faster
so it just feels like we're in like in
boiling water we won't know as it's
happening
I would like to I'm not afraid of AGI
I'm excited about it there's always
concerns but I would like to know when
it happens
yeah or and have like hints about when
it happens like a year from now it will
happen that kind of thing yeah I just
feel like in the digital realm it just
might happen yeah I think all we have
available to us because no one has built
AGI again so all we have available to us
is uh is there enough fertile ground on
the periphery I would say yes and we
have the progress so far which has been
very rapid and uh there are next steps
that are available and so
I would say uh yeah it's quite likely
that we'll be interacting with digital
entities how will you know that
somebody's birthday it's going to be a
slow I think it's going to be a slow
incremental transition is going to be
product based and focused it's going to
be GitHub co-pilot getting better and
then uh GPT is helping you write and
then these oracles that you can go to
with mathematical problems I think we're
on a on the verge of being able to ask
very complex
questions in chemistry physics math of
these oracles and have them complete
Solutions
so AGI to use primarily focused on
intelligence so Consciousness doesn't
enter
into uh into it
so in my mind Consciousness is not a
special thing you will you will figure
out and bolt on I think it's an emerging
phenomenon of a large enough and complex
enough
um generative model sort of so
um if you have a complex and Alpha World
model that understands the world then it
also understands its predicament in the
world as being a language model which to
me is a form of Consciousness or
self-awareness and so in order to
understand the world deeply you probably
have to integrate yourself into the
world yeah and in order to interact with
humans and other living beings
Consciousness is a very useful tool I
think Consciousness is like a modeling
insight
modeling insights yeah it's a you have a
powerful enough model of understanding
the world that you actually understand
that you are an entity in it yeah but
there's also this um perhaps just a
narrative we tell ourselves there's a it
feels like something to experience the
world the hard problem of Consciousness
yeah but that could be just the
narrative that we tell ourselves yeah I
don't think what yeah I think it will
emerge I think it's going to be
something uh very boring like we'll be
talking to these uh digital AIS they
will claim they're conscious they will
appear conscious they will do all the
things that you would expect of other
humans and uh it's going to just be a
stalemate I I think there would be a lot
of actual fascinating ethical questions
like Supreme Court level questions
of whether you're allowed to turn off a
conscious AI if you're allowed to build
the conscious AI
maybe there would have to be the same
kind of debates that you have around
um sorry to bring up a political topic
but you know abortion uh which is at the
deeper question with abortion
is what is life and the Deep question
with AI is also what is life and what is
conscious and I think that'll be very
fascinating
to bring up it might become illegal to
build systems that are capable that like
of such level of intelligence that
Consciousness would emerge and therefore
the capacity to suffer would emerge and
some A system that says no please don't
kill me well that's what the Lambda
compute the Lambda chatbot already told
um this Google engineer right like it it
was talking about not wanting to die or
so on so that might become illegal to do
that right
I because otherwise you might have a lot
of a lot of creatures that don't want to
die and they will uh you can just spawn
Infinity of them on a cluster
and then that might lead to like
horrible consequences because then there
might be a lot of people that secretly
love murder and they'll start practicing
murder on those systems I mean there's
just I to me all of this stuff just
brings a beautiful mirror to The Human
Condition and human nature we'll get to
explore it and that's what like the best
of uh the Supreme Court of all the
different debates we have about ideas of
what it means to be human we get to ask
those deep questions that we've been
asking throughout human history there's
always been the other in human history
uh we're the good guys and that's the
bad guys and we're going to uh you know
throughout human history let's murder
the bad guys and the same will probably
happen with robots it'll be the other at
first and then we'll get to ask
questions of what does it mean to be
alive what does it mean to be conscious
and I think there's some Canary in the
coal mines even with what we have today
um and uh you know for example these
there's these like waifus that you can
like work with and some people are
trying to like this company is going to
shut down but this person really like
yeah love their waifu and like is trying
to like Port it somewhere else and like
it's not possible and like I think like
definitely uh people will have feelings
towards uh towards these um systems
because in some sense they are like a
mirror of humanity because they are like
sort of like a big average of humanity
in a way that trained it but we can that
average we can actually watch it's nice
to be able to interact with the big
average of humanity yeah and do like a
search query on it yeah yeah it's very
fascinating and uh we can also of course
also like shape it it's not just a pure
average we can mess with the training
data we can mess with the objective we
can fine tune them in various ways so we
have some
um you know impact on what those systems
look like if you want to achieve AGI
um and you could have a conversation
with her and ask her uh talk about
anything maybe ask her a question what
kind of stuff would you would you ask I
would have some practical questions in
my mind like uh do I or my loved ones
really have to die uh what can we do
about that
do you think it will answer clearly or
would it answer poetically
I would expect it to give Solutions I
would expect it to be like well I've
read all of these textbooks and I know
all these things that you've produced
and it seems to me like here are the
experiments that I think it would be
useful to run next and here's some Gene
therapies that I think would be helpful
and uh here are the kinds of experiments
that you should run okay let's go over
this thought experiment okay
imagine that mortality is actually uh
like a prerequisite for happiness so if
we become immortal we'll actually become
deeply unhappy and the model is able to
know that so what is it supposed to tell
you stupid human about it yes you can
become immortal but you will become
deeply unhappy if if the model is if the
AGI system
is trying to empathize with you human
what is this supposed to tell you that
yes you you don't have to die but you're
really not going to like it
is that is it going to be deeply honest
like there's a Interstellar what is it
the AI says like humans want 90 honesty
so like you have to pick how honest do I
want to answer these practical questions
yeah I left AI Interstellar by the way I
think it's like such a sidekick to the
entire story but
is at the same time it's like really
interesting it's kind of limited in
certain ways right yeah it's limited and
I think that's totally fine by the way I
don't think uh I think it's
fine and plausible to have a limited and
imperfect agis
is that a feature almost as an example
like it has a fixed amount of compute on
its physical body and it might just be
that even though you can have a super
amazing Mega brain super intelligent AI
you could also can have like you know
less intelligent AIS that you can deploy
in a power efficient way and then
they're not perfect they might make
mistakes no I meant more like say you
had infinite compute and it's still good
to make mistakes sometimes
like in order to integrate yourself like
um
what is it going back to Goodwill
Hunting uh Robin Williams character
says like the human imperfections that's
the good stuff right isn't it isn't that
this like we don't want perfect we want
flaws in part to form connections with
each other because it feels like
something you can attach your feelings
to
the the flaws in that same way you want
an AI That's flawed I don't know I feel
like perfectionist but then you're
saying okay yeah but that's not AGI but
see AGI would need to be intelligent
enough to give answers to humans that
humans don't understand and I think
perfect isn't something humans can't
understand because even science doesn't
give perfect answers there's always gabs
and Mysteries and I don't know I I don't
know if humans want perfect
yeah I can imagine just uh having a
conversation with this kind of Oracle
entity as you'd imagine them and uh yeah
maybe it can tell you about
you know based on my analysis of Human
Condition uh you might not want this and
here are some of the things that might
but every every dumb human will say yeah
yeah trust me I can give me the truth I
can handle it but that's the beauty a
lot of people can choose uh so but then
the old marshmallow test with the kids
and so on I feel like too many people
uh like it can't handle the truth
probably including myself like the Deep
truth of The Human Condition I don't I
don't know if I can handle it like what
if there's some dark stuff what if we
are an alien science experiment and it
realizes that what if it had I mean
this is the Matrix you know the middle
over again
I don't know I would what would I talk
about I don't even yeah I
uh probably I will go with the save for
scientific questions at first that have
nothing to do with my own personal life
immortality just like about physics and
so on yeah uh to build up like let's see
where it's at or maybe see if it has a
sense of humor that's another question
would it be able to uh presumably in
order to if it understands humans deeply
would able to generate
uh yep to generate humor yeah I think
that's actually a wonderful Benchmark
almost like is it able I think that's a
really good point basically to make you
laugh yeah if it's able to be like a
very effective stand-up comedian that is
doing something very interesting
computationally I think being funny is
extremely hard yeah
because
it's hard in a way like a touring test
the original intent of the touring test
is hard because you have to convince
humans and there's nothing that's why
that's what comedians talk about this
like there's this is deeply honest
because if people can't help but laugh
and if they don't laugh that means
you're not funny they laugh that's funny
and you're showing you need a lot of
knowledge to create to create humor
about like the occupational Human
Condition and so on and then you need to
be clever with it